voice actor Billy West pulled from two
major old-timey Inspirations to create
Dr Zoidberg actor and host George gessel
I certainly want to thank Phil for that
warm introduction I was listening to it
for a minute and I thought I was dead
and actor Lou Jacoby I just cut the 745
elevator down from six both of those
Inspirations definitely give a Jewish
and a Yiddish flavor to the character
which West says he thought was
appropriate given the traditionally
Jewish bird suffix of the name Zoid
meanwhile is a futuristic alien sounding
word that has personal significance for
Futurama producer and writer David X
Cohen who while in high school created a
computer game named Zoid he submitted it
to brooderburn software which not only
rejected it but spelled Cohen wrong in
the rejection letter which it seems like
something that could happen to Dr
Zoidberg